Hey, David, if Trump doesn't run in 2024 24,
could Tucker Carlson be the future of Trump
ism and or the Republican Party?
So at this point, before I even talk about
Tucker, anybody who hears that question and
says Tucker Carlson, Fox News propagandist
could never be the Republican nominee seems
premature.
I am nowhere near as confident as people saying
that about those proclamations.
Look at 2016.
OK, who would have thought a few years prior
that Trump would be the Republican nominee?
You know, forget about president, but the
Republican nominee.
So if you say, listen, it could be Tucker,
listen, it could be Don Jr..
Listen, it could be the my pillow guy.
I would rule nothing out at this point because
if the Republican electorate has proven anything
over the last four years, it's that they can
be bamboozled into choosing almost quite literally
anyone, maybe not anyone, but almost anyone
as their nominee.
And they've proven that by how easily they
were bamboozled by Donald Trump in 2016.
Now, Tucker, specifically in twenty twenty
four first, I think it's too early.
And the reason it's too early is that 2024
is going to likely be more about coalitions
than the individual.
So could it be that the coalitions get behind,
Tucker?
Sure.
Could it be that the coalitions get behind
Marco Rubio?
Maybe.
Could it be that they get behind, you know,
the my pillow guy?
The reason I would rule nothing out is that
you have actual Trump cultists right now.
These are the people chanting Fox News sucks
outside of voting vote count locations.
These are the people who email me and they
say, David, don't you realize Trump is getting
four more years?
You've got the Trump cultists, you then have
the Republican loyalists.
Now, I'm kind of slicing and dicing this a
little bit differently than I often do.
Often I say you've got the pro-business people,
the libertarian people and the evangelical
religious right.
This is different because it's more voting
contingencies.
I'm talking about Trump cultists, Republican
loyalists in which I include the social conservatives,
the evangelical types, et cetera, people who
are more on cultural issues and because of
socialism and so on, voting for Republicans.
And then I've got these kind of economic conservatives
and those are the people that were most likely
to not like Trump because they found all of
the other stuff pretty distasteful.
It's people who basically want relatively
low regulation and lower taxes and business
freedom, but they're not social conservatives
and they find Trump to be a buffoon.
I think that that first group, the Trump cultists,
mostly disappears unless Trump simply keeps
going and campaigns all through the next four
years and runs in twenty, twenty four to once
again be the Republican nominee.
If Trump doesn't do that, I believe that the
Trump cultists are the group that will determine
whether the Republican Party goes back to,
like, you know, Jeb, that type of thing in
twenty, twenty four, or whether Trump or someone
wacky could be the nominee again.
Do the Trump cultists become normal conservative
Republicans?
Do the Trump cultists fragment and take away
from the Republican Party by creating some
new coalition?
Do the Trump called this, many of which were
never even paying attention to politics before
Trump?
Do they just get back out of politics altogether
and go back to wherever they were before?
I do think it would be a mistake to say that
it was only Trump's celebrity prior to 2016
that gave him the cult.
Like following the celebrity may well have
helped, but what really gave Trump the cult
like following was that he tapped into these
ideas that were really bolstered during the
Obama era, including just standard racism,
but also the idea of working class whites
feeling like they are losing privileged status,
not saying that they rightly felt that, but
they felt it.
And the sort of xenophobic stuff that was
often kind of scattered and not above the
surface, Trump was able to say to all those
people, come to the surface, say this stuff
publicly, you are with me.
That's how he developed the cult.
Like following the celebrity certainly helped.
And so I think those are all factors we have
to think about going into twenty, twenty four.
But I would rule out nothing.
In terms of could it be, Tucker?
Sure.
Could it be, you know, Ivanka, it could be.
I would rule nothing out at this point.